the Joe Rogan experience thing about
extraterrestrials you believe in it
well you know I believe in this well you
believe in everything the reality and
toys that can harass you as a child
there's there's no evidence but the
numbers of humans I mean the numbers of
planets rather that could support humans
they're they're pretty well just what
we've documented so far it's pretty
interesting just what they know about
the thousands of plans to discover
there's hundreds that could possibly
support human life and then there's
hundreds of billions of galaxies right
the idea that we're the only one not
only that neil degrasse tyson's explain
this to me as a mindfuck and a half that
the universe is so big that not only is
there another you out there that has
done everything exactly as you've done
to every pause mm-hmm like that pause
every pause down to the second yeah an
infinite number yeah yeah you're talking
about is it called the infinite in an
infinite universes there's this exact
conversation happening yet people look
exactly like that because infinity
implies that and the emotion in
variations right there's one when you
get up right now and you have to take a
piss right out of the room or
Charlemagne's there you're there I'm
there there's one would you get mad that
we don't believe you that you saw
Bigfoot or something you know that kind
of [ __ ] yeah this the idea that when you
think of infinity right we think about
its being really big it's not it's
impossible yeah to put in your head yeah
the infinite infinite universes like the
size of the universe 14 billion
light-years apart
infinite numbers of those not only that
they think that inside every galaxy is a
supermassive black hole and inside that
black hole maybe another universe with
hundreds of billions of galaxies with
hundreds of billions of black holes
inside each one of those hundreds of
billions of galaxies hundreds of
billions of black holes that it's
fractal and that it's impossible for you
to even conceive yeah I think it's very
so you're saying just based on the
numbers there has to be something only
life in this book you think well the
only life in the universe I'm just
saying like hmm
whether or not it's reached us it well
yeah I don't think it's reached us and
if it has reached us it's like they have
to find a way to bend time right time is
the biggest issue no I'm
with the problem like we're earthlings
right yeah and if you look at how
diverse the earth is like there's
different species of [ __ ] in the woods
different [ __ ] in the water different
species of [ __ ] in the jungle different
species of [ __ ] in the sky why wouldn't
the earth be I mean the universe be just
as diverse yeah and we're assuming
shortage we're assuming we're the
smartest life form in the universe no no
I'm not at all and sure it is all I'm
saying is life has an end right what is
the the oldest species on the earth
right now where the turtles lived like
200 as I'm sure like that what who lives
so let's say it's 200 300 years right
let's say that's the max now we have 300
years to travel millions of light-years
away to get to another galaxy to see
other planets to see if they have some
[ __ ] and may have the same for us so
let's say there is another species did
somehow found a way to take you the
consciousness that they have and put it
in a robot that can then last for
thousands of years then they would have
the opportunity to come here but we're
limited by time right
you will die before you get somewhere
like I can go to Mars we can't come back
think well I think we're basing that off
our intelligence there might be a
species in this universe that can fly to
earth the way we fly to LA but that's
what I'm saying they would have an end
time not necessarily what they could do
is fold time or fold it whatever you
don't even cry that wormhole thing where
you're going where instead of it's not
linear it's whatever event horizon they
talked about how they did that yeah but
and there's another one too at Matthew
McConaughey oh yeah yeah interstellar
yeah where they get into like space-time
space-time is really interesting right
it's like the faster you go the the less
you age yeah right like so somebody's in
a plane colliders into someone here on
the earth right so someone's flying
around the earth in a plane versus us
sitting on earth they will age for
actually less right so if you just
increase their speed and decrease hours
when that or key bars are the same they
will let's say not age at all compared
to us aging like 30 years even crazier
Brian Cox I want to see his cosmos
exhibit that's the the physicist oh he's
a physicist okay from CERN from the
Large Hadron Collider yeah
budget podcasts and shows he said that
if you were born and right next to you
like your mother and you both put on a
watch at the moment you were born and
then you checked that watch 30 years
later if you have a perfect watch it was
never out of time your watch would have
a different time than her watch because
you have gone through time differently
than she has fraction I don't yeah
fractionally because the amount of how
fast you travel mmm it you you you
experience time in a different way the
path you take in life the different
terrain you travel over the earth all
those factors play in to how much time
has passed let's say you leave on the
top of a mountain and she lives at the
bottom you're actually traveling at a
faster rate right because it's no
different than like let's say there's a
ball on a tether right and you're just
swinging it around in a circle right the
ball at the end is actually going faster
than your hand in the middle swinging
around right so since you're going
faster actually aging slower and we're
talking about fractions of seconds yeah
but over the course of time it proves
that everyone experiences time at a
slightly different rate which proves
Einstein's theory that if you travel
very fast in a spaceship and then come
back you would look at your brother who
was your age and now he's a hundred
years old and you're 30 so I think I
figured it out how we can time travel or
not time travel but I think I figured it
all right now so we're trying to create
okay and again I don't know [ __ ] but
this is just me like you know this is
brilliant idiot [ __ ] right here ok
so what we have to do is go faster than
the speed of light in order time-travel
I don't know how to do that just yet but
what I think we can do is we're trying
to use like rockets to propel us at a
certain mile per hour to get close to
the speed of light [ __ ] the [ __ ] the
Rockets why don't we use light as wind
and create a sail that harness light and
that sail will naturally take us the
same speed or as close as we possibly
could get to the speed of light they did
in a movie called sunshine I'm a [ __ ]
genius
sunshine how could you see that movie I
don't even know what an elk is science
fiction science fiction movie I'm
talking to Bob Lazar tonight those the
guy was telling you I wanted to bring
you to dinner I'm going to as well if
you want to go he's a guy who worked at
area 51 and I didn't even know if we'd
talk about it tomorrow yeah bring it up
Oh area 51 is real but this guy
literally worked on what he says are
alien spacecrafts spacecraft that sail
on sunshine could be the next big thing
bro you should work for now Jamie this
is public school education get you a job
at Trump's space for that's it I don't
want to do any other matters I just want
to throw the ideas out there and I think
I got it and Mel this is a legit space
for shirt from trumps from Trump Tower
Tim Tim I love you had a friend who
works on alien spacecraft oh I don't
know I told you tonight on the podcast
tomorrow unless he worked at area 51 is
he allowed to talk about that see what I
get in here is because he's been talking
about it for decades really yeah and
they've tried to discredit him there's a
he's very controversial a lot of people
think he's full of [ __ ] but the Maury
there's a recent documentary by Jeremy
Corbyn the more you look at the
documentary he knows too many things he
knows too many things that that prove
that he absolutely worked at area 51 he
got arrested for bringing people to a
lookout peak to look over where the area
where they would launch these spaceships
and he's got video of these things
flying through the air doing all these
maneuvers that no conventional
spacecraft could do in 1980 whatever the
[ __ ] was were you gonna arrest it
[Applause]